ليست ساحه الحرب لكنها في قلبها بيلاروسيا
التي بقيت وفيه لتحالفها الوثيق مع الروس
لم تخذلهم في حربهم على اوكرانيا تربط
البلدين اتفاقيات امنيه ودفاعيه عده
والعمل الماضي شكل قوه دفاع اقليميه
مشتركه لذلك واكثر لا يجد الرئيس الروسي
افضل من اراضي بيلاروسيا لتخزين اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه وذكرما يقول الكرملين ان
الرئيس البيلاروسي الكسندر لوكاشينكو
يطرحه منذ وقت طويل طبيعي ان تثور
التكهنات بشان التوقيت والمخاوف بشان
الدوافع والغايات فبيلاروسيا تشترك في
حدود مع ثلاث دول اعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي هي بولندا وليتوانيا
لكن موسكو وهي تطمئن العالم تبقي عينها
على ما يفعل الاخرون
فالولايات المتحده تفعل ذلك فقد نشرت
اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه منذ مده طويله في
اوروبا على اراضي ست دول من حلفائها في
النيتو سنفعل الشيء ذاته من دون انتهاك
التزاماتنا الدوليه في اطار معاهده منع
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه يتريث الغرب في
تفاعله مع المساله
فواشنط لا ترى مؤشرات على استعداد روسيا
لاستخدام السلاح النووي ولا داعيا لتعديل
الوضع النووي الاستراتيجي لكن الالتزام
الامريكي يتجدد بمبدا الدفاع الجماعي لحلف
شمال الاطلسي الحلف نفسه لم يرى اي
تغييرات في وضع روسيا النووي تدفع لتعديل
وضعه مع ان النيتو كما قال متحدث باسمه
متيقظ ويراقب الموقف
اما مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي فبدا له ان استضافه بيلاروسيا
اسلحه نوويه روسيه ستعني تصعيدا غير مسؤول
وتهديدا للامن الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل الذي
انذر سلطات منسك بمزيد من العقوبات قال
انه لا يزال بامكانها ايقاف التصعيد
والتهديد في الجانب الاوكراني دعوه من
الخارجيه لجلسه طارئه لمجلس الامن ردا على
الخطوه الروسيه بينما يحذر رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي والدفاع الاوكراني اليك من
ان الخطوه الروسيه قد تزعزع الاستقرار في
بيلاروسيا وبيلاروسيا كما بدات للرجل
اخذها الروس
رهينه نوويه